- Bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica.
Meu nome é John Watrous e sou o Diretor Técnico de
Educação na IBM Quantum.
Esta é a sétima aula da série e nesta aula vamos discutir o problema de estimação de fase e como podemos resolvê-lo
com um computador quântico.
Em seguida, vamos aplicar a estimação de fase ao problema de fatoração de inteiros, que discutimos na aula anterior.
O que vamos obter é o algoritmo de Shor, que permite fatorar inteiros
com custo polinomial ou em tempo polinomial, se preferirmos
pensar em termos do tempo necessário em vez do número de
operações elementares que precisamos.
Esta é a joia da coroa dos
algoritmos quânticos em certo sentido, e embora fatorar inteiros grandes
possa ter utilidade limitada para a maioria das pessoas, continua sendo uma das peças de evidência mais
convincentes que temos para a hipótese de que os computadores quânticos vão
oferecer vantagens extraordinárias
sobre os computadores clássicos. Aqui está uma visão geral da aula.
Vamos começar com uma definição do próprio problema de estimação de fase e, em seguida, vamos discutir um método para resolver esse problema
com um computador quântico.
Vamos fazer isso passo a passo, começando com o que você pode
pensar como uma espécie de aquecimento.
No problema de estimação de fase, o objetivo é aproximar
um certo número real e nessa parte de aquecimento
vamos ver como podemos obter
uma aproximação de precisão muito baixa
para esse número.
Isso não vai ser
suficiente para fatoração quando aplicarmos nossa solução ao
problema de estimação de fase à fatoração de inteiros,
na verdade vamos precisar de uma aproximação de precisão bastante alta, mas ainda assim é útil começar com esse tipo de aquecimento
só para ter uma ideia de
como a coisa toda funciona.
Em seguida, vamos discutir a questão de como podemos obter mais precisão, e isso vai levar muito
naturalmente a uma operação conhecida como a Transformada de Fourier Quântica.
Vamos ver exatamente o que é essa operação e como ela pode ser implementada
com um quantum circuit.
E assim que tivermos isso, vamos conseguir aplicá-la
à estimação de fase para chegar a um procedimento geral para resolver o problema
com precisão muito alta.
Então, na última parte da aula, vamos ver como uma solução para
o problema de estimação de fase nos permite fatorar inteiros eficientemente.
E especificamente o que vamos obter é o algoritmo de Shor para
fatoração de inteiros, ou pelo menos algo que é equivalente ao algoritmo de Shor.
A forma como isso funciona é que basicamente nos damos
um trampolim, que é mais um problema chamado o problema de encontrar a ordem.
E em particular vamos ver como podemos resolver o problema de encontrar a ordem usando o procedimento de estimação de fase e depois vamos ver como
podemos fatorar inteiros
resolvendo o problema de encontrar a ordem. Vamos começar com um caso especial de um teorema chamado o Teorema Espectral,
e especificamente vamos focar no que o teorema nos
diz para matrizes unitárias.
O teorema espectral é
um teorema muito importante da álgebra linear e
da análise funcional.
Ele nos diz algo interessante sobre como certas aplicações lineares podem ser expressas em uma certa forma, geralmente chamada de
decomposição espectral,
que é útil por muitas razões.
E como eu disse, vamos focar no que esse teorema nos diz
para matrizes unitárias.
O teorema espectral é
mais geral do que isso. Ele não funciona para todas as matrizes, mas funciona para uma classe de matrizes
chamadas matrizes normais, que incluem todas as matrizes unitárias, bem como algumas matrizes
que não são unitárias.
Mas só para manter as coisas simples, vamos restringir nossa atenção
às matrizes unitárias por enquanto, pois é tudo que precisamos para
os propósitos desta aula.
Aqui está um enunciado do teorema espectral apenas para matrizes unitárias.
Suponha que U é uma
matriz unitária N por N.
O que o teorema diz
é que deve existir uma base ortonormal de
vetores, psi um até psi N,
junto com N números complexos
Lambda um até Lambda N, todos situados no círculo unitário complexo, de forma que U pode ser expresso
como temos nessa equação.
Isso é chamado de decomposição
espectral de U, como já mencionei, e pode ser muito conveniente saber que U pode ser escrito dessa forma.
Às vezes pode ser conveniente ter esses vetores e esses números quando estamos trabalhando com
uma determinada matriz unitária U, e também pode ser muito
útil simplesmente saber
que tal expressão é sempre possível como uma forma de provar certas coisas sobre matrizes unitárias, por exemplo.
Neste enunciado do teorema, cada um desses números,
Lambda um até lambda N, é escrito de uma forma específica
como E elevado à potência dois pi I vezes theta onde cada um dos thetas
theta um até theta N é um número real, e
vamos voltar a essa forma
de escrever cada um desses
números em um momento.
Uma coisa importante a notar
sobre esses vetores e números é que cada vetor psi
K deve ser um autovetor da matriz U com
autovalor correspondente lambda K.
O que significa que se
multiplicarmos psi K por U, o que obtemos é lambda K vezes psi K.
Então o que U faz com cada um desses vetores é simplesmente multiplicá-lo pelo número correspondente lambda K.
Em geral, para algum vetor arbitrário, não é assim que U funciona, mas autovetores são especiais.
E o que o teorema nos diz é que existe de fato
uma base ortonormal desses autovetores.
Esta equação aqui embaixo, por sinal, decorre da expressão que temos para U a partir do teorema, junto com o fato de que
os vetores são ortonormais.
Se você multiplicar a
expressão de U por qualquer psi K e usar a ortonormalidade dos vetores, você vai obter uma soma em que
todos os termos são zero
exceto um deles, e o único termo com que
ficamos parece com isso.
Agora podemos definir o
problema de estimação de fase.
O problema é um pouco
incomum como vamos ver.
São nos dados duas coisas. Primeiro, é nos dada a descrição de um quantum circuit unitário,
que age em N qubits
para alguma escolha de N, e quando dizemos que esse
é um circuit unitário,
queremos dizer apenas que todos os
gates são unitários, então não há medições
nesse circuit.
Segundo, é nos dado um estado psi de N qubits, e essa é a parte incomum.
Na verdade temos uma entrada de estado
quântico para esse problema, e é uma única cópia desse estado.
Para todos os outros problemas computacionais de que falamos nesta série, a entrada foi clássica, seja na forma de uma cadeia
de bits ou como uma caixa preta.
E isso não é surpreendente porque os problemas
computacionais que encontramos no nosso dia a dia tendem a ser clássicos,
pois são os
problemas que mais nos importam.
A forma como você pode
pensar sobre esse problema é que ele é algo que aparece ou provavelmente vai aparecer como um subproblema.
E o procedimento de estimação de fase que vamos eventualmente desenvolver é algo que
geralmente usamos como uma sub-rotina
dentro de alguma computação maior, presumivelmente uma para um problema clássico
do qual nos importamos.
Agora, esse vai ser um problema com promessa e o estado psi não é
qualquer estado quântico qualquer.
É prometido que psi é um autovetor de qualquer operação unitária U que o circuit dado descreve.
E o objetivo é encontrar ou
aproximar o autovalor que corresponde ao autovetor psi.
Vamos enunciar o problema de forma
um pouco mais precisa.
A entrada consiste em um
quantum circuit unitário em N qubits, que pode ser codificado como uma cadeia de bits
usando qualquer método que preferirmos para codificar descrições de quantum circuit, junto com um estado psi de N qubits.
Podemos chamar o circuit do que quisermos, mas o que realmente importa em termos do enunciado desse problema é a própria operação unitária
que é realizada quando o circuit é executado, e essa operação unitária
é descrita pela Matriz U.
Mas não nos é dado U como uma matriz, apenas nos é dada a descrição de um quantum circuit que implementa U.
A promessa, como já enunciei, é que psi é um autovetor de U.
Então se executarmos nosso circuit em psi, obteríamos psi saindo multiplicado pelo autovalor seja lá qual for,
o que seria uma fase global
nessa situação.
E finalmente, a saída do problema é uma aproximação do autovalor correspondente a psi, e especificamente estamos procurando
uma aproximação do número real theta, entre zero e um, incluindo
zero, mas não incluindo um
que satisfaz a equação
que temos na tela.
Para explicar essa forma de
parametrizar o autovalor correspondente a psi, e também para esclarecer o que queremos dizer com uma aproximação,
vamos desenhar uma figura do
círculo unitário complexo.
Podemos colocar os números um, I,
menos um e menos I em seus lugares usuais e podemos considerar
algum ponto arbitrário no
círculo parametrizado por theta como temos no enunciado do problema.
Este é o ponto que
obtemos se começarmos em um e rotacionarmos por um ângulo de
dois vezes pi vezes theta, então o ângulo não é
theta, é dois pi theta,
e outra forma de pensar sobre isso é que se começarmos em um e percorrermos uma distância de dois pi theta no próprio círculo,
chegaremos ao nosso ponto, E elevado a
dois vezes pi vezes theta.
Cada ponto no círculo unitário complexo pode ser representado dessa forma
para uma escolha única de theta.
E isso porque damos
uma volta completa no círculo quando theta vai de zero a um, e se fôssemos todo o
caminho até theta igual a um,
voltaríamos ao ponto de partida
em theta igual a zero, e por isso incluímos zero, mas não incluímos um.
Só para garantir que cada
ponto no círculo unitário complexo corresponde a um valor único de theta no intervalo que estamos considerando.
Existem várias formas
que poderíamos imaginar para aproximar um determinado valor de theta, mas a forma que vamos fazer é aproximar theta por uma fração,
onde o denominador
é dois elevado à potência M para alguma escolha de um inteiro positivo M, e o numerador é um inteiro y
entre zero e dois elevado a M menos um.
Você pode pensar nisso como uma aproximação de M bits para theta se quiser, e poderíamos escrever esse
número em notação binária
onde temos um ponto binário seguido da representação
binária de Y.
Digo ponto binário a propósito
em vez de ponto decimal porque decimal significa base 10 e estou falando de base dois
aqui, mas é a mesma ideia.
Mas de qualquer forma podemos
também simplesmente pensar nisso como uma fração como
aparece na tela.
E para ficar claro, quando pensamos em
aproximações nesse contexto, deve-se entender
que valores de theta
próximos a zero e valores de theta próximos a um estão de fato próximos entre si.
Então por exemplo, se theta é igual a 0,99 e aproximamos esse valor
de theta pelo valor zero,
essa é uma boa aproximação no sentido de que está
dentro de um centésimo do valor real, quando
damos a volta no círculo
e voltamos a zero quando chegamos a um.
O termo módulo um às vezes é usado para descrever a situação, onde estamos essencialmente
equiparando theta igual a um com theta igual a zero.
O ponto é que realmente nos importamos com a localização do ponto
E elevado a dois pi I theta no círculo unitário,
e pensar sobre essa
forma de aproximar theta faz sentido quando temos esse objetivo em mente.
O próprio enunciado do problema,
como aparece na tela, não é específico sobre quão boa a aproximação de theta precisa ser,
mas isso é algo que podemos ajustar dependendo das nossas necessidades.
Em algumas situações podemos estar satisfeitos com uma aproximação de baixa precisão
para theta, e em outras situações podemos exigir
uma aproximação de precisão muito alta, e o próprio enunciado do problema
pode ser refinado de acordo.
A seguir vamos ver como podemos resolver
o problema de estimação de fase com um computador quântico e
vamos começar com um aquecimento.
Essa não vai ser nossa solução final
para o problema.
O que vamos fazer é usar o fenômeno de phase kickback para tentar aprender algo
sobre o autovalor correspondente a um dado autovetor.
Lembre que no
problema de estimação de fase nos é dada a descrição
de um quantum circuit unitário para alguma operação U,
e o que fazemos primeiro é
usar essa descrição do circuit para criar um novo circuit que implementa uma operação U controlada como
está ilustrado na tela.
Isso é bastante simples de fazer. O que podemos fazer é adicionar um qubit de controle, que está ilustrado no
topo neste diagrama
e usar esse novo qubit de
controle como controle para cada gate único que
aparece no nosso circuit.
Assim todos os gates são aplicados se esse qubit de controle estiver definido como um, e nenhum deles é aplicado se o qubit de controle estiver definido como zero,
Isso significa que vamos
precisar de uma versão controlada de cada gate que
aparece no circuit U, mas não precisamos pensar
sobre esses novos gates controlados
como gates únicos se não quisermos. Eles poderiam ser implementados
como pequenos circuits feitos de gates de qualquer conjunto de gates
que escolhemos usar. E assim que tivermos uma
versão controlada de U, podemos considerar executar esse circuit,
onde primeiro colocamos o qubit de controle em uma superposição de zero e um, aplicamos o gate U controlado ao autovetor psi que nos é dado,
e depois aplicamos um Hadamard gate
ao controle e medimos.
Vamos ver por que faz sentido fazer isso conforme passamos pela análise, mas mesmo antes de chegarmos aos detalhes, podemos ver imediatamente uma semelhança
com o algoritmo de Deutsch por exemplo, onde estamos aplicando
alguns Hadamard gates e medindo como forma
de efetivamente sondar
o que é que alguma operação dada
está fazendo aqui.
É um unitário controlado
em vez de um gate de consulta, mas há ideias muito semelhantes em jogo.
Então vamos ver o que o circuit faz.
O estado inicial é o autovetor psi, em produto tensorial com o estado zero
para o qubit de controle,
aplicar o primeiro Hadamard gate transforma o estado do
qubit do topo para um estado mais e podemos expandir o estado completo
como está mostrado aqui.
Em seguida aplicamos a operação U controlada e o que ela faz é aplicar U a psi quando o qubit de controle está definido como um,
mas não quando está definido como zero. Então obtemos o estado pi dois
que está escrito na tela.
Podemos simplificar o estado
usando o fato de que psi é um autovetor de U com autovalor e elevado a dois pi I theta.
Então obtemos esse autovalor multiplicando o segundo
termo, mas não o primeiro.
E podemos simplificar usando a bilinearidade
do produto tensorial.
Então o que temos aqui é o fenômeno de phase kickback, mas desta vez está acontecendo para algum autovetor psi arbitrário de alguma operação unitária U arbitrária,
ao contrário de uma operação not sendo aplicada a um estado menos mais especificamente.
Então esse é o estado após a operação U controlada ser aplicada.
A propósito, vale a pena
tirar um momento para notar que o estado dos N qubits inferiores ainda é o autovetor psi.
O que é ótimo porque isso
nos dá a oportunidade de usá-lo novamente se quisermos.
Então o segundo Hadamard gate é realizado e aqui está o estado que obtemos.
E eu não mostrei todos os
detalhes da derivação aqui, mas se você aplicar o
Hadamard gate e simplificar, é isso que você deve obter.
Então esse é o estado logo
antes da medição.
Podemos focar nesse estado para ver o que podemos aprender
sobre theta ao medir.
E se medirmos o qubit
do topo ou o qubit mais à direita, essas são as probabilidades que obtemos para os dois resultados.
E aqui usei
algumas fórmulas básicas que relacionam senos e cossenos
a exponenciais complexas para expressar essas probabilidades
em termos de senos e cossenos.
Especificamente, a probabilidade de obter zero é o cosseno ao quadrado de pi vezes theta e a probabilidade de obter um
é o seno ao quadrado do mesmo ângulo. E isso faz sentido
porque o seno ao quadrado mais o cosseno ao quadrado de
qualquer ângulo é igual a um.
Então nossas probabilidades
somam um como esperamos.
E aqui está um gráfico dessas probabilidades como função de theta.
Para ficar claro, este é um gráfico das
próprias probabilidades ao contrário de um gráfico que representa uma única distribuição de probabilidade, por exemplo.
Por exemplo, se theta
é igual a um meio, então a probabilidade de
obtermos o resultado um, que está desenhado em roxo, é igual a um
enquanto a probabilidade
de obter o resultado zero, que está desenhado em azul, é zero.
Por outro lado, se theta é igual a um
quarto ou três quartos, então temos que cada um dos dois resultados é igualmente provável.
E claro que para todas as escolhas de theta, a soma das probabilidades é igual a um como já observamos.
Portanto não aprendemos exatamente qual é
theta com esse procedimento, mas ele nos dá alguma
informação sobre theta.
E se imaginarmos uma situação em que é prometido
que theta é igual a zero ou theta é igual a um meio, esse procedimento vai nos dizer
exatamente qual das
duas possibilidades é.
Então essa é uma forma simples de usar o fenômeno de phase kickback para aprender algo sobre o autovalor.
Então como podemos aprender mais
sobre o autovalor?
Bem, essa é uma situação em que podemos deixar
a ignorância ser nossa guia.
Porque realmente não há
muitas coisas que podemos fazer.
Não sabemos quase nada
sobre o autovetor psi, e também não sabemos
muito sobre a operação U.
Temos um circuit para U, mas por tudo que sabemos pode ser uma
bagunça horrível e confusa que não vamos conseguir
entender ao examiná-lo.
Mas uma opção natural é executar o circuit várias vezes.
Em particular, poderíamos tentar fazer exatamente a mesma coisa que acabamos de fazer, exceto que em vez de aplicar apenas uma única operação U controlada,
aplicamos essa operação duas vezes. Ou poderíamos aplicá-la qualquer número de vezes, mas vamos começar com duas
só para ver o que acontece.
Bem, o que acontece é na verdade bastante
simples. Ao aplicar a
operação U controlada duas vezes, estamos efetivamente apenas
elevando o autovalor ao quadrado
porque ele vai ser chutado para a
fase do qubit do topo duas vezes em vez de apenas uma.
E então quando pensamos
sobre as probabilidades de resultado como uma função de theta, estamos essencialmente apenas
dobrando a frequência.
Para cada possível escolha de theta, as probabilidades de resultado
são as mesmas que seriam se dobrássemos theta e depois
pegássemos a parte fracionária
para obter um número entre zero e um.
Por exemplo, se theta
é igual a um meio, então o autovalor é menos um.
Então ao aplicar U duas vezes estamos efetivamente elevando o autovalor ao quadrado e o resultado é o mesmo que seria para theta igual a zero.
Ou seja, a probabilidade
do resultado zero, ilustrada em azul, é igual a um, e a probabilidade do resultado um, ilustrada em roxo, é igual a zero.
Isso é muito simples, mas podemos de fato obter
algumas informações adicionais sobre theta fazendo isso.
Por exemplo, se soubermos com antecedência que theta é igual a zero ou theta igual a um quarto, então esse circuit vai nos revelar
qual das duas possibilidades é.
Por outro lado, não podemos mais distinguir o caso em que theta é igual a zero do caso em que theta é igual a um meio.
Então esse procedimento não é estritamente melhor do que o anterior quando
tínhamos um único gate U de controle, mas ao também executar esse circuit
podemos ganhar informações adicionais.
Não está imediatamente claro
como as informações adicionais que podemos obter ao iterar a operação U controlada várias vezes
podem ser reconciliadas com
a informação que obtemos ao realizá-la apenas uma vez, e na verdade há múltiplas
formas de proceder.
Por exemplo, há uma técnica chamada estimação de fase iterativa, que envolve executar circuits como os que vimos,
junto com algumas variações menores sobre eles, para chegar a uma aproximação de theta.
Mas vou descrever
o que poderia ser chamado de uma abordagem mais tradicional, onde usamos um único quantum circuit que tem múltiplos qubits de controle
que controlam diferentes
números de iterações da operação unitária U.
Primeiro vou descrever como isso
funciona para dois qubits de controle e depois um pouco mais tarde vamos generalizá-lo para mais de dois qubits de controle.
Aqui está um quantum circuit
que usa dois qubits de controle.
O qubit de controle do topo
controla uma única operação U enquanto o qubit do segundo a partir do topo controla duas cópias de U.
Então o que estamos fazendo é combinar os dois circuits que vimos anteriormente, de uma forma que faz uso da única cópia
do autovetor psi que temos.
No entanto, você vai notar
que os Hadamard gates após as operações U controladas foram removidos e ainda não há medições.
O que vamos fazer é
ver como esse circuit funciona e depois vamos descobrir
o que devemos fazer com os dois qubits do topo
para aprender o máximo possível sobre o valor theta que
estamos tentando aproximar.
Após os Hadamard gates realizados, temos o estado que está
mostrado na tela.
E essa vai ser uma forma conveniente de escrever o estado para
ver o que acontece a seguir.
A zero e A um são bits, e se pensarmos sobre os dois qubits do topo como sendo um registrador de dois qubits,
estamos pensando sobre A zero, que corresponde ao qubit do topo como sendo o bit menos significativo, e A um que corresponde
ao qubit de controle inferior
como sendo o bit mais significativo.
Após a primeira operação U
controlada ser realizada, obtemos esse estado.
O estado clássico correspondente ao qubit de controle do topo é A zero, então o resultado do phase kickback
pode ser expresso dessa forma. Depois após a segunda e
terceira operações U controladas
serem realizadas, obtemos esse estado.
A ideia é a mesma que para o primeiro, exceto que desta vez estamos aplicando a operação U controlada duas vezes.
Então multiplicamos A um por dois no
expoente para refletir isso.
E agora podemos simplificar essa expressão pensando sobre os bits
A um e A zero juntos como um inteiro entre zero e
três usando notação binária.
Ou seja, quando pensamos
sobre a cadeia de dois bits, A um A zero, como a codificação
binária de um inteiro,
o que obtemos é dois
vezes A um mais A zero.
E o entendimento é
que quando escrevemos Cat X, estamos falando sobre X escrito como uma cadeia binária de comprimento
dois usando notação binária.
Então agora vamos focar
nesses dois qubits de controle para descobrir o que podemos
aprender sobre theta com eles neste momento.
Os N qubits restantes estão
ainda no mesmo estado psi que nos foi originalmente dado, o que é realmente uma coisa maravilhosa sobre essa abordagem
porque como eu disse antes, podemos usar esse estado novamente se quisermos ganhar ainda mais
informações sobre theta.
Mas por enquanto, vamos apenas pensar sobre o que podemos aprender com
esses dois qubits de controle.
Para nos ajudar a descobrir como proceder, vamos imaginar que é prometido que theta é igual a Y sobre quatro
para algum inteiro y entre zero e três.
Em geral, theta pode não
ser um desses quatro valores, mas este é um caso natural a considerar.
Vimos na versão original de qubit de controle único do procedimento que se fosse prometido que theta é zero ou um meio
o circuit revelaria qual é. E também notamos que na versão onde aplicamos a
operação U controlada duas vezes,
poderíamos perfeitamente discriminar o caso em que theta é igual a zero do caso em que theta
é igual a um quarto.
Então podemos esperar que com nosso novo circuit possamos discriminar esses quatro casos.
Em essência, o que estamos
fazendo é usar a noção de problema com promessa
para tornar o problema mais fácil, para que possamos ver como proceder.
E isso não é uma má ideia, em geral. Se você tem um problema e não
sabe como resolvê-lo, tente torná-lo mais fácil.
Se você conseguir resolver o problema mais fácil, o insight que ganhar pode ser útil para resolver o problema mais geral.
E se não conseguir resolver o problema mais fácil, provavelmente não está pronto
para o problema mais geral.
Então continue tornando-o mais fácil
até conseguir resolvê-lo.
De qualquer forma, voltando ao nosso problema, vamos definir um estado de dois qubits para cada um dos valores possíveis de Y.
Em outras palavras, phi Y é igual ao estado
mostrado no topo da tela quando theta é escolhido
especificamente para ser Y sobre quatro.
E aqui estão esses quatro
estados escritos explicitamente.
Então só para reiterar, se
theta é igual a Y sobre quatro para Y sendo zero, um, dois, ou
três e executarmos nosso circuit,
vamos ficar com
um desses quatro estados, aquele que corresponde
ao valor correto de Y.
E só queremos descobrir
qual é.
E a pergunta é, isso é possível?
E a resposta a essa pergunta é sim, porque esses quatro estados são ortogonais.
Se você calcular o produto interno
entre qualquer par deles, vai obter zero.
E como são ortogonais, podem ser perfeitamente discriminados por uma medição projetiva.
E em particular podemos
expressar tal medição definindo uma projeção para cada vetor como temos aqui.
Isso sempre funciona, sempre que
temos uma base ortonormal, e você pode verificar isso
em relação às definições que vimos na aula três
para esse caso específico
se quiser. Então concluímos que é
possível realizar nossa tarefa,
que é aprender o valor de Y a partir do estado que está mostrado
no topo da tela.
E se quisermos fazer isso
com um quantum circuit, podemos proceder como vou explicar agora.
Primeiro podemos definir uma matriz unitária V cujas colunas são os quatro
vetores listados em ordem.
Essa matriz terá a ação descrita na parte inferior da tela,
nos estados da base padrão,
e podemos escrever a matriz
para ver como ela é.
Como V mapeia cada estado da base padrão, kappa Y para o vetor phi Y, temos que ao aplicar V dagger,
ou em outras palavras V inverso a phi Y vai transformar de volta para o estado da base padrão correspondente.
Então o que podemos fazer é aplicar V dagger a qualquer estado que
obtivemos do nosso circuit.
E então se realizarmos uma
medição na base padrão, vamos obter o número Y
que estamos procurando, expresso como uma cadeia
de comprimento dois em binário.
Antes de continuar, vamos falar um pouco mais
sobre a matriz unitária V.
Essa é uma matriz especial e
você pode já tê-la visto antes.
É a matriz associada
a uma operação linear em vetores de quatro dimensões conhecida como a transformada discreta de Fourier.
Para ser mais preciso, a transformada discreta de Fourier pode ser definida para qualquer
dimensão inteira positiva, e vamos dar uma olhada nela
em geral em alguns momentos.
E é assim que ela
parece especificamente quando a dimensão é igual a quatro.
Podemos pensar sobre a
transformada discreta de Fourier de diferentes formas.
Podemos pensar sobre ela de forma puramente abstrata como uma aplicação linear em vetores que pode ser representada por uma matriz.
E também podemos pensar sobre
ela como um problema computacional onde nos é dado um vetor, e queremos calcular o resultado
de aplicar essa aplicação linear.
Esse acaba sendo um problema computacional incrivelmente importante,
e há um algoritmo altamente eficiente para realizar esse cálculo
conhecido como a transformada rápida de Fourier.
De fato, esse é um problema tão importante em processamento de sinal, por exemplo, que a transformada rápida de
Fourier é considerada por muitos
como um dos algoritmos mais importantes e consequentes
já descobertos.
Também podemos pensar sobre a
transformada discreta de Fourier como uma operação quântica unitária que pode ser aplicada a
um vetor de estado quântico.
E quando pensamos sobre ela dessa forma, a chamamos de quantum Fourier
transform, ou QFT para abreviar.
Matematicamente falando, é essencialmente a mesma coisa que a transformada discreta de Fourier, mas a chamamos de quantum Fourier transform
apenas para esclarecer que é uma operação sendo aplicada a um vetor de estado quântico.
Então vamos mudar o nome da nossa matriz, de V para QFT quatro para refletir o fato
de que a operação que chegamos é de fato a quantum Fourier transform.
Então aqui está o circuit completo para aprender o valor de Y quando é prometido que
theta é igual a Y sobre quatro
para Y sendo zero, um, dois, ou três.
E só para deixar claro, estamos aplicando o inverso da
quantum Fourier transform, ou em outras palavras QFT quatro dagger
para mapear um dos quatro estados possíveis de volta ao estado da base padrão, cat Y, para que possamos recuperar Y ao medir.
Então esse é o circuit que
obtemos ao pensar sobre a versão com promessa do
problema de estimação de fase, onde é prometido que theta
é zero, um quarto, um
meio, ou três quartos, mas não há nada que nos impeça
de executar esse circuit para
um valor arbitrário de theta.
E se fizermos isso, aqui
estão as probabilidades para os quatro
resultados possíveis que obtemos.
Cada um dos quatro valores
possíveis para Y tem sua própria cor, e o gráfico nos diz
quais são as probabilidades para cada um como função de theta.
Por exemplo, se theta
é igual a três quartos, obteremos o resultado
três com probabilidade um,
enquanto as probabilidades para os outros três resultados são todas zero como já sabemos ao pensar sobre a versão com promessa do problema.
Se theta está próximo de três quartos mas não é exatamente três quartos, haverá alguma probabilidade não nula associada aos outros resultados,
mas ainda vamos obter o resultado
três com alta probabilidade.
Então mesmo que theta possa
não ser igual a Y sobre quatro, ainda podemos pensar
sobre o resultado que obtemos das medições dividido por quatro
como sendo um palpite ou uma
aproximação para theta.
O palpite pode estar errado, mas ainda assim está
nos fornecendo informações.
E uma coisa que podemos
aprender do gráfico é que as melhores aproximações sempre têm as maiores
probabilidades associadas a elas.
Quando digo melhor aproximação, quero dizer qualquer valor de Y sobre quatro que está mais próximo do valor real de theta,
no sentido de módulo um. O pior caso possível é que theta está exatamente a meio caminho entre
dois valores de Y sobre quatro.
Por exemplo, se theta é igual
a três oitavos ou 0,375, nesse caso vemos
que as aproximações
um quarto e dois quartos
ou um meio são igualmente boas.
Então nesse caso específico
há na verdade duas melhores aproximações em vez de uma.
E somos igualmente propensos a obter o resultado um
e o resultado dois.
Os outros dois resultados zero e três, que não fornecem aproximações muito boas
para theta quando dividimos por quatro, aparecem de fato com alguma probabilidade
que parece ser pouco
menos de 10% em ambos os casos.
Então esse procedimento não é perfeito, mas nos fornece informações.
E é notável que
independentemente de theta, é garantido que vamos sempre sortear a melhor aproximação
ou uma das duas melhores aproximações quando há empate, com probabilidade que
parece ser pouco acima de 40%.
E quanto mais próximo theta
está da aproximação, maior a probabilidade de ver o valor correspondente de Y.
E isso é uma melhoria bastante
significativa em relação a usar um único qubit de controle.
Esse é de fato o procedimento de
estimação de fase quando escolhemos usar dois qubits de controle.
E o que vamos fazer a seguir é generalizar esse
procedimento de forma natural, onde não paramos em
apenas dois qubits de controle
mas usamos quantos
qubits de controle quisermos.
E o que vamos ver é que ao
generalizar o procedimento, ao adicionar mais qubits de controle, seremos capazes de obter cada vez mais
aproximações precisas de theta. E esse será o procedimento geral
de estimação de fase.
Para generalizar o
procedimento de estimação de fase de dois qubits de controle
para quantos quisermos, vamos precisar entender
como a quantum Fourier transform é definida para outras dimensões.
E também vamos precisar discutir como ela pode ser implementada
com um quantum circuit.
Aqui está a definição da
quantum Fourier transform quando a dimensão é um
inteiro positivo arbitrário N.
Aqui estamos pensando sobre essa operação como sendo uma operação em um sistema cujos estados clássicos são
zero até N menos um.
E aqui a matriz que
descreve essa operação foi expressa usando
a notação direta.
Também podemos descrevê-la em termos de sua ação
nos estados da base padrão, só para conectá-la com
o que já vimos quando N é igual a quatro.
Então é assim que parece
quando N é igual a um, que não é um caso muito interessante.
Aqui está para N igual a dois, e você vai notar que o que obtemos nesse caso é uma operação Hadamard.
Aqui está a quantum Fourier
transform para N igual a três.
Para N igual a quatro, que
já vimos.
E para um último exemplo, aqui está quando N é igual a oito.
Assim como tínhamos antes
para o caso N igual a quatro, essas são as matrizes que associamos com a transformada discreta de Fourier
para cada uma das dimensões. Mas a chamamos de
quantum Fourier transform quando queremos pensar sobre
ela como uma operação quântica.
Às vezes, a propósito, o fator principal de um sobre a raiz quadrada de N não é incluído quando pensamos sobre a transformada discreta de Fourier como uma matriz,
mas precisamos desse fator aqui para garantir que obtemos uma matriz unitária.
Às vezes também há um sinal de menos em cada um dos expoentes, mas não sempre.
É basicamente apenas uma preferência pessoal que não muda a natureza fundamental
da transformada.
Mas de qualquer forma, vamos definir a quantum Fourier transform como está escrito aqui na tela.
Há uma notação de abreviação muito útil
que é comum e vamos usá-la
um pouco mais tarde na aula.
E é definir um
número complexo omega N, como temos aqui.
Especificamente como e elevado a dois pi I sobre N, que também pode ser escrito
usando senos e cossenos
como temos aqui. Às vezes chamamos esse
número de N-ésima raiz da unidade porque quando o elevamos
à potência N, obtemos um.
Aqui está uma figura que mostra alguns exemplos.
Omega um é igual a um, omega dois é igual a menos um, e omega quatro é igual a I.
Em geral para obter omega N, podemos imaginar dividir o círculo unitário em N pedaços de tamanho igual como se fosse uma pizza sendo compartilhada por N pessoas
e omega N está no
canto do primeiro pedaço, assumindo que o outro canto
desse pedaço está em um.
Então em particular quando N
fica cada vez maior, os pedaços ficarão cada vez menores, e omega N ficará
cada vez mais próximo de um.
E agora se usarmos essa notação podemos expressar a
quantum Fourier transform de uma forma um pouco mais limpa.
Às vezes essa notação
ajuda a manter as coisas simples como vamos ver acontecer
um pouco mais tarde na aula.
Há uma implementação eficiente em quantum circuit
da quantum Fourier transform
quando N é uma potência de dois,
que vamos agora examinar. Embora tendemos a definir a
quantum Fourier transform para qualquer dimensão N,
só vamos precisar dela
no caso em que N é uma potência de dois, para generalizar o
procedimento de estimação de fase.
A implementação vai
usar controlled phase gates que são representados como
temos aqui na tela.
Eles parecem dois
controles conectados junto com um número que
é alpha nesse caso.
E a ação desse gate é descrita pela matriz que está mostrada aqui.
Esses são literalmente
controlled phase gates, significando que temos um qubit de controle que controla um phase gate.
Vimos phase gates lá atrás na aula um.
Mas para phase gates especificamente, na verdade não importa
qual qubit é o controle e qual é o alvo.
E vimos isso na aula dois, para o caso específico de um Z gate.
E agora que temos essa noção, podemos passar para como a
quantum Fourier transform pode ser implementada.
A implementação é recursiva por natureza e talvez a forma mais fácil
de descrevê-la em termos simples seja dar um exemplo que
pode ser facilmente generalizado.
Aqui está como podemos fazer isso
quando N é igual a 32.
Então há cinco qubits.
Para ficar claro, estamos associando os
estados da base padrão desses cinco qubits com os inteiros entre zero e 31 usando notação binária.
A primeira coisa que fazemos é realizar a quantum Fourier
transform para N igual a 16 em todos os qubits exceto o qubit menos significativo,
que é o de cima. E essa é a parte
recursiva da construção.
Então para implementar essa operação, temos que seguir o mesmo
padrão mas com um qubit a menos.
E no caso base temos
apenas um único qubit para o qual a quantum Fourier transform é apenas um Hadamard gate.
Depois de aplicar o QFT em todos os qubits exceto o do topo, aplicamos um conjunto de controlled phase gates usando as fases que são
indicadas no diagrama.
Em seguida aplicamos um Hadamard
gate ao qubit do topo, e redistribuímos os qubits um pouco usando alguns swap gates.
Esses swap gates têm o efeito de permutar ciclicamente os qubits o que é necessário para fazer
a construção funcionar.
Podemos seguir exatamente o mesmo padrão para outras escolhas de N
desde que sejam potências de dois, onde sempre começamos os
controlled phase gates
com alpha sendo pi sobre
dois para o qubit inferior e dividindo por dois cada vez
movendo para a esquerda no diagrama
para obter as fases subsequentes. Agora não é nada óbvio
que essa construção funciona.
E não vou explicar
por que funciona neste vídeo.
Se você estiver interessado em ver
os detalhes de por que funciona, pode encontrá-los no
conteúdo escrito da aula.
Direi, no entanto, que
o que está sendo explorado aqui é a estrutura básica das
transformadas discretas de Fourier
e na verdade é exatamente
a mesma estrutura que permite a transformada rápida
de Fourier funcionar.
Outra forma de dizer isso é que se olharmos para a transformada rápida de Fourier, podemos pensar sobre ela em
termos de quantum circuits.
E esse é o circuit que obtemos.
Então quantos gates precisamos no total para essa implementação?
Para descobrir isso, vamos deixar SM ser o número de gates que
precisamos quando temos M qubits.
Quando M é igual a um, precisamos apenas de um único gate porque o QFT é apenas uma operação Hadamard nesse caso.
Se M é pelo menos dois, então esses
são os gates que precisamos.
Primeiro precisamos de SM menos um gates para a quantum Fourier
transform em M menos um qubits, seja lá qual for esse número.
Também precisamos de M menos um
controlled phase gates, M menos um swap gates,
e um Hadamard gate adicional.
Então aqui está uma expressão
de SM em ambos os casos quando M é igual a um e
quando M é pelo menos dois.
Esse é um exemplo do que é chamado de relação de recorrência e
aparece muito comumente na análise de algoritmos.
Esse em particular
acaba sendo muito simples e tem uma chamada
expressão de forma fechada, que podemos obter somando.
Para ser preciso, o valor de SM é a soma dos primeiros M
inteiros ímpares consecutivos, que é igual a M ao quadrado,
como você pode ter encontrado antes ou talvez apenas tenha percebido
em algum momento da sua vida.
E acontece de ser bastante fácil provar que essa fórmula é verdadeira por indução em M
caso você esteja interessado em uma prova formal.
Então é isso. Podemos implementar a
quantum Fourier transform em M qubits usando M ao quadrado gates.
Só um par de observações adicionais muito
rápidas.
Primeiro, na verdade não
precisamos de todos os swap gates que descrevi.
É possível efetivamente
empurrá-los todos para o final contanto que ajustemos em quais qubits os controlled phase gates
atuam de forma adequada.
E se fizermos isso, vamos precisar apenas de
M sobre dois swap gates no total arredondando para baixo.
Ainda teremos um custo quadrático, mas o número de gates pode ser reduzido dessa forma mesmo assim.
E uma observação final é que podemos de fato reduzir ainda mais o custo se estivermos dispostos a nos contentar com
uma aproximação razoavelmente boa.
Por exemplo, quando M fica grande, muitos dos controlled phase gates estão bastante próximos da
operação identidade,
e eliminar os
que são muito próximos pode nos economizar bastante em gates enquanto ainda nos dá uma
aproximação razoavelmente boa.
Também é possível aproximar a quantum Fourier transform
com circuits muito rasos, ou seja, com pequena profundidade, caso isso seja algo
que desejamos fazer.
E agora que sabemos o que é a
quantum Fourier transform para diferentes dimensões, bem como como ela pode ser implementada quando a dimensão é uma potência de dois,
podemos voltar ao
procedimento de estimação de fase e ver como ele pode ser generalizado onde usamos algum
número arbitrário M de qubits de controle.
Aqui está como o procedimento parece como um quantum circuit para
uma escolha arbitrária de M.
Temos M qubits de controle no topo, que assumimos estar todos
inicializados no estado zero.
Aplicamos um Hadamard
gate a cada um deles e então cada um é
usado como um qubit de controle para aplicar alguma potência da
operação unitária U,
onde dobramos o número
de vezes que U é aplicado para cada qubit de controle.
Aqui nesse diagrama indiquei isso incluindo as potências
em U dentro das caixas em vez de mostrar o gate U controlado
sendo aplicado aquele número de vezes, como forma de tanto tornar
o diagrama mais claro quanto economizar espaço para
que caiba na tela.
Agora a primeira coisa que precisamos notar
sobre esse procedimento é que ele pode se tornar muito caro.
Em particular estamos
dobrando o número de vezes que cada operação U é aplicada
para cada qubit de controle.
E se a forma como fazemos isso é simplesmente iterar um gate U controlado quantas vezes precisarmos,
vamos obter um circuit enorme. Ele será exponencialmente
grande no número M.
Essa é uma limitação importante em geral, e em particular limita nossa capacidade de obter aproximações precisas
de autovalores.
No caso específico de fatoração no entanto, ao qual chegaremos em breve, acontece que somos muito afortunados e podemos usar um truque que nos permite
evitar esse crescimento exponencial no custo.
Mas em geral para operações
unitárias U arbitrárias, isso não será possível e
vamos pagar um preço alto
por aumentar o
número de qubits de controle.
Não vou fazer
uma análise detalhada do circuit neste vídeo e em vez disso vou apenas mencionar que há uma expressão bastante simples para o estado
logo antes das medições que está mostrado aqui na tela.
A partir desse estado podemos obter uma expressão para as probabilidades
dos vários resultados, e ela acaba parecendo com isso.
E assim que tivermos essa expressão,
podemos racionalizar sobre ela, e realmente essa expressão
é tudo de que precisamos para continuar.
Como eu disse, não vou entrar
nos detalhes neste vídeo, mas você pode encontrá-los no
conteúdo escrito da aula e acontece que na verdade não é tão complicado,
então confira se estiver interessado. Se fizermos a análise, o que encontramos é que a situação
não é tão diferente
do caso M igual a dois, exceto que obtemos mais precisão.
Em particular, podemos pensar
primeiro sobre a probabilidade de obter a melhor ou uma das
duas melhores aproximações,
que podemos expressar como temos aqui.
Você pode ignorar esse subscrito de um no valor absoluto se quiser.
Esse é apenas um símbolo que podemos
usar para nos lembrar que estamos falando sobre
aproximações no círculo onde pensamos sobre theta igual a zero
e theta igual a um como sendo o mesmo. O ponto aqui é que
estamos pensando sobre qualquer escolha de Y que torna Y sobre dois elevado à potência M
o mais próximo possível de theta.
E mais uma vez, assim como
tínhamos para o caso M igual a dois, é garantido que vamos obter esse resultado Y com probabilidade de pelo menos 40%.
Na verdade, a probabilidade é
de pelo menos quatro sobre pi ao quadrado, que é um pouco mais de 40%.
Dez não é uma aproximação ruim
para pi ao quadrado quando você está com pressa.
E isso é na verdade bastante notável. Estamos falando de obter a melhor
aproximação para theta como uma fração Y sobre dois elevado à potência M
onde Y é um inteiro. E estamos obtendo a
melhor aproximação com probabilidade maior que 40%.
Também podemos pensar sobre
aproximações que são piores.
Especificamente vamos imaginar
que Y não é tão bom assim, e mais especificamente vamos supor
que há uma
aproximação melhor para theta da mesma forma que fica entre theta e Y sobre dois elevado a M,
que pode ser expressa como
está escrito na tela.
Em tal caso a
probabilidade de obter esse Y será relativamente pequena, no máximo 25%.
Na verdade será menor que isso, mas 25% é o que obtemos de
uma análise bastante simples, e é suficiente.
Como exemplo. Aqui está o gráfico que obtemos quando usamos três qubits de controle
em vez de dois.
Desta vez estou
plotando apenas as probabilidades para os resultados três, quatro e cinco porque não quero que a
figura fique muito bagunçada.
Quando theta é igual a
um meio por exemplo, é garantido que vamos obter o resultado quatro.
E então tomamos nossa
aproximação como quatro oitavos ou um meio porque dois elevado à
potência três é oito.
E nesse caso estamos exatamente certos. E contanto que theta esteja mais próximo de um meio do que estaria de digamos três
oitavos por exemplo,
obtemos o resultado quatro com uma probabilidade mais alta
do que o resultado três.
E com probabilidade,
novamente maior que 40%.
Aqui está o gráfico quando M é igual a quatro. E as curvas na verdade
parecem praticamente idênticas, exceto que agora nos aproximamos
por um fator de dois.
Então agora os resultados que são plotados incluem sete, oito e nove e estamos tomando a aproximação como sendo um desses números
dividido por 16 em vez de oito.
E vou mostrar mais um gráfico onde aumentamos para M igual a cinco.
E de novo vamos
nos aproximar por um fator de dois.
E aqui está. Mais uma vez as curvas parecem
praticamente idênticas, mas estamos efetivamente
dobrando nossa precisão.
E como antes obtemos a melhor aproximação para theta, com probabilidade maior que 40%.
Isso é bastante incrível. Mas se 40% não for suficiente
como medida de confiança,
o que podemos fazer é executar o procedimento um número pequeno de vezes, e
tomar a moda dos resultados, ou seja, aquele que
aparece com mais frequência.
E se fizermos isso, será extremamente provável que acabemos com uma aproximação muito boa para theta.
Lembre a propósito que toda vez que executamos o
procedimento de estimação de fase temos que o autovetor
sai sem alterações.
Então ele está disponível para executarmos o procedimento
várias vezes como este.
Em resumo, estamos coletando
estatísticas sobre theta, e o ponto é que ao fazer isso podemos obter uma aproximação muito precisa
para theta
com alta confiança, e não precisamos de muitas iterações do procedimento para fazer isso.
E é assim que o procedimento de
estimação de fase funciona.
Na última parte da aula, vamos aplicar a técnica
de estimação de fase ao problema de fatoração de inteiros.
Como mencionei no início do vídeo, a forma como isso funciona é que consideramos um problema intermediário conhecido como o problema de encontrar a ordem.
Vamos ver como podemos resolver
o problema de encontrar a ordem usando a estimação de fase, e depois vamos discutir brevemente como resolver o problema de encontrar a ordem
nos permite fatorar inteiros eficientemente.
A segunda parte é completamente clássica e vou apenas resumir a
ideia básica neste vídeo.
Mas vamos começar com o
problema de encontrar a ordem.
Primeiro, vamos obter uma
notação útil.
Para todo inteiro positivo N, definimos ZN como sendo os inteiros
zero até N menos um.
Então por exemplo, Z um tem um
único elemento que é zero, Z dois tem os elementos zero e um,
Z três tem os elementos zero,
um e dois, e assim por diante.
Então ZN é um conjunto.
Mas também podemos pensar sobre
ele como mais do que um conjunto. Podemos pensar sobre operações aritméticas como adição e multiplicação em ZN
definindo-as módulo N.
Por exemplo, vamos supor
N é igual a sete.
Temos que três e cinco
são elementos de Z sete e se os multiplicarmos obtemos 15
que deixa um resto de
um após dividir por sete.
Às vezes expressamos isso escrevendo que três vezes cinco é
congruente a um módulo sete, como está escrito aqui.
Mas também podemos simplesmente escrever que três vezes cinco é igual a um.
Claro que três vezes cinco
normalmente não é igual a um, é igual a 15.
Mas quando está claro que
estamos trabalhando em Z sete significando que a multiplicação
é definida módulo sete,
podemos simplesmente escrever que
três vezes cinco é igual a um.
Agora entre os elementos
de ZN para qualquer N positivo, alguns deles vão ter
MDC igual a um com N
e outros não. E os elementos que têm MDC igual a um com N são especiais.
e escrevemos ZN estrela para nos referir ao conjunto apenas desses elementos.
Então por exemplo, aqui está Z 21 estrela.
Entre os elementos de Z 21, dos quais há 21 claro, acontece que 12 deles têm MDC igual a um
com 21 e o restante não.
Em particular sempre que
temos um elemento de Z 21 que é divisível por três ou sete, pulamos ele.
Há várias razões
pelas quais esse conjunto é especial, e uma das razões é que sempre que temos um elemento de ZN estrela
e consideramos as potências inteiras positivas
desse número, sempre vamos eventualmente
chegar ao número um,
onde assim como antes estamos falando sobre multiplicação módulo N.
o menor expoente inteiro positivo que nos dá um é chamado
a ordem desse elemento.
Por exemplo, pense no elemento A igual a quatro em Z 21 estrela.
quatro vezes quatro é 16, que não é igual a um módulo 21, mas se multiplicarmos por quatro mais uma vez,
obtemos 64, e 64 módulo
21 é igual a um.
Então a ordem de quatro módulo 21 é três.
Chegar a um assim sempre acontece para todos os elementos de ZN estrela.
E a propósito, nunca
acontece para elementos de ZN que não estão em ZN estrela.
Então ter MDC igual a
um com N como esse é tanto necessário quanto
suficiente para que isso aconteça.
E só para concluir o
exemplo de N igual a 21, aqui estão os menores
expoentes inteiros positivos para os quais isso funciona para
cada elemento de Z 21 estrela,
e podem ser verificados um a um.
E agora podemos enunciar o
problema de encontrar a ordem, que é simplesmente encontrar a ordem para um dado elemento em ZN estrela.
Para ser preciso, a entrada é
dois inteiros positivos A e N para os quais o MDC é igual a um,
e a saída é o
menor inteiro positivo R tal que A elevado à potência R é
congruente a um módulo N,
ou equivalentemente o
menor inteiro positivo R para o qual A elevado a R é igual a um.
Assumindo que estamos fazendo aritmética em ZN.
Acredita-se que este seja um problema
computacionalmente difícil, nenhum algoritmo clássico eficiente
é conhecido para resolvê-lo.
E como vamos discutir o problema é pelo menos tão difícil quanto
a fatoração de inteiros no sentido de que se tivéssemos um algoritmo para resolver o encontro de ordem,
seríamos capazes de usar esse algoritmo para resolver o problema de
fatoração de inteiros eficientemente.
Na verdade, o contrário também vale, ou seja, se você tiver um algoritmo para fatoração, pode usá-lo para resolver
o problema de encontrar a ordem.
Então os dois problemas são
em certo sentido equivalentes em termos de sua
dificuldade computacional.
Agora vamos ver como podemos resolver
o problema de encontrar a ordem em um computador quântico
usando a estimação de fase.
Para fazer uma conexão entre os problemas, vamos imaginar que temos um sistema cujo conjunto de estados clássicos é AN.
Para qualquer escolha de um elemento A em ZN estrela, vamos definir uma operação
MA como temos aqui.
Em palavras o que MA faz é multiplicar por A, e aqui a multiplicação é módulo N.
E pelo restante desta aula, você deve sempre pensar sobre
expressões dentro de cats como sendo calculadas módulo N,
só para manter as coisas simples e não precisarmos continuar
escrevendo mod N repetidamente.
Essa é uma operação unitária, mas isso só é verdade
porque A está em ZN estrela.
Se o MDC de A e N não for um, essa operação não será unitária.
Aqui está um exemplo. Se N é igual a 15 e A é igual a dois, que está em Z 15 estrela, então
essa é a ação de M dois.
E se examinar esse
exemplo por alguns momentos, você vai ver que o que está acontecendo é que os elementos de ZN estão sendo apenas permutados por essa ação.
Então é tanto determinístico quanto unitário, o que quer dizer que como uma matriz, MA é uma matriz de permutação.
E aqui está a ideia principal. Os autovalores de MA estão
muito estreitamente conectados
com a ordem de A. E ao usar a estimação de fase para aproximar esses
autovalores com precisão suficiente
podemos determinar a ordem de A. Então quais exatamente são os autovetores e os autovalores de MA?
Bem, não vamos precisar de todos eles, precisamos apenas de alguns deles.
Vamos começar com um exemplo fácil.
Aqui está um autovetor de MA, nomeamos ele como psi zero, e ele é dado pela
soma de cat um, cat a,
cat A ao quadrado, e assim por diante até cat A elevado à potência R menos um, todos divididos pela raiz quadrada de R
para torná-lo um vetor unitário. Aqui R é a ordem de A.
E vou reservar a
letra R para a ordem de A pelo restante da aula.
Então sempre que você ver R, essa é a ordem de A para
qualquer A que estamos discutindo.
O autovalor associado
a esse autovetor é um.
E podemos verificar isso
aplicando MA a esse vetor para ver o que obtemos.
MA multiplica por A, então
precisamos apenas aumentar cada um dos expoentes em
um e é isso que obtemos.
Mas a ordem de A é R, então A elevado à potência R é igual a um.
E podemos fazer essa substituição.
Mas esse é o mesmo vetor
com que começamos. Tudo o que fizemos foi
embaralhar os cats mas estamos tomando a soma então
isso não muda nada.
Então MA vezes psi zero é igual a psi zero.
Então é um autovetor de
MA com autovalor um.
Esse é um exemplo muito simples
de um autovetor e para identificar mais deles, vamos lembrar a mesma notação que tínhamos mais cedo na aula.
Omega R é o número
complexo no círculo unitário que obtemos ao tomar E elevado à
potência de dois vezes pi vezes I
dividido por R. Da última vez tínhamos um N em vez de um R, mas ainda funciona da mesma
forma com R no lugar de N.
Precisamos desse número porque
ele vai aparecer nos outros autovetores
de MA que vamos identificar.
E agora que lembramos dessa notação, podemos observar que esse
vetor chamado psi um também é um autovetor de MA.
É semelhante a psi zero, temos exatamente os mesmos cats e estamos somando-os e
dividindo pela raiz quadrada de R.
Mas desta vez temos várias fases multiplicando cada um dos cats.
Omega R elevado a menos um para A, omega R elevado a menos dois para A ao quadrado, e assim por diante até omega R elevado à
potência menos R menos um
para A elevado à potência R menos um. Então a potência de omega R
é sempre menos um vezes qualquer que seja a potência de A
que aparece dentro do cat.
Não vou passar pelos detalhes, mas está mostrado na tela caso você queira assistir novamente o vídeo e pausar conforme necessário.
Mas se fizermos a multiplicação e simplificarmos novamente usando o fato de que A elevado à potência R é igual a um
bem como o fato muito importante de que omega elevado à potência R é igual a um, o que vamos encontrar é que temos
novamente um autovetor de MA.
Desta vez ao fazer a simplificação, vamos precisar extrair um fator de omega R para ver que de fato temos um autovetor
e que o vetor de omega R representa o autovalor associado a esse autovetor.
Então esse é um segundo par
autovetor-autovalor de NA.
Podemos identificar autovetores adicionais usando exatamente o mesmo raciocínio, E de fato, se simplesmente substituirmos omega R
por omega R elevado à potência J para cada J entre zero e R menos um, sempre obteremos um autovetor,
e o autovalor associado será omega R elevado à potência J.
Então isso na verdade inclui
psi zero e psi um, que já vimos
bem como R menos dois, outros pares autovetor-autovalor.
Todos funcionam basicamente da mesma forma, e para verificá-los, precisamos apenas saber que A elevado à potência R é igual a um
bem como que omega R elevado à
potência R é igual a um.
Existem outros autovetores de MA como cat zero por exemplo, mas eles não serão úteis para nós e não precisamos nos preocupar com eles.
Precisamos nos preocupar apenas com psi zero até psi R menos um.
Vamos focar em psi um por um momento, apenas para tentar entender por que nos importamos com esses autovetores
e o que eles podem nos dizer
sobre a ordem R, que é o que estamos tentando encontrar.
Supondo que nos é dado
o autovetor psi um, podemos tentar aprender
R da seguinte forma.
Primeiro, realizamos a estimação de
fase nesse autovetor usando um quantum circuit que
implementa a operação MA.
O que obtemos é uma aproximação para theta, que é um sobre R nesse caso.
E segundo porque estamos procurando R e temos uma
aproximação para um sobre R, a coisa natural a fazer é
calcular o recíproco
e arredondá-lo para
o inteiro mais próximo. Temos que arredondar assim
porque R tem que ser um inteiro.
Mas não temos um sobre R exatamente, apenas temos uma aproximação para ele.
Mas se a aproximação for suficientemente boa, obteremos R ao arredondar,
que é o que estamos procurando.
E agora a pergunta é quanta precisão precisamos para determinar corretamente R calculando o recíproco e arredondando?
Ou em outras palavras, quão precisa nossa
aproximação precisa ser para fazer tudo isso funcionar?
Bem, acontece que precisamos de uma aproximação bastante precisa.
Por exemplo, não podemos
nos dar ao luxo de confundir um sobre R com um sobre R mais um, ou um sobre R menos um, por exemplo.
Essas duas frações, um sobre R mais um e
um sobre R menos um estão bastante próximas de um
sobre R quando R é grande.
Mas embora precisemos de uma
aproximação bastante precisa, não precisamos de uma aproximação ridiculamente
precisa, e pode-se mostrar que
se nossa aproximação
satisfaz a desigualdade que
temos aqui na tela, então o arredondamento vai
nos dar a resposta certa.
Não vou tentar argumentar isso neste vídeo, mas está mostrado no
material escrito para a aula caso você esteja interessado nos detalhes.
E se essa é a precisão
que estamos buscando, então é suficiente usar um
número de qubits de controle no procedimento de estimação de fase
que é igual a duas vezes
o comprimento de N mais um.
Onde como tínhamos nas aulas anteriores, o comprimento de N é o número de bits que precisamos para expressar N em binário.
A propósito, se estivermos satisfeitos
em obter a melhor aproximação com probabilidade de pelo menos 40% e não tentarmos
aumentar nossa confiança
como descrevi anteriormente, então na verdade não precisamos do mais um.
Mas de qualquer forma, temos que o número
de qubits de controle que precisamos é linear no comprimento de N
escrito como uma cadeia binária.
Vimos que se tivermos
o autovetor psi um, podemos usar a estimação de fase para encontrar R, desde que usemos precisão suficiente.
Infelizmente não é tão fácil obter esse autovetor.
Então vamos fazer uma pergunta diferente.
Suponha que não temos psi um, mas sim psi
para uma escolha aleatória de J.
Ainda assim podemos descobrir qual é R? Ou pelo menos podemos
descobrir algo sobre R?
E a resposta é sim, podemos descobrir algo
sobre R, pelo menos em média.
O que podemos fazer é tentar
descobrir J sobre R usando um método muito semelhante
ao que acabamos de ver,
mas com uma diferença fundamental.
Primeiro, vamos fazer exatamente a
mesma coisa que fizemos antes, que é executar o procedimento de
estimação de fase no autovetor psi J.
E o que vamos obter é uma
aproximação para J sobre R, ao contrário de um sobre R,
que era o que tínhamos antes.
Mas agora temos um pequeno problema, porque calcular o
recíproco não vai nos dar R, vai nos dar R sobre J.
E a propósito, não estamos
assumindo que sabemos qual é J, simplesmente nos é dado psi J para um J aleatório,
e não nos é dito qual é J. Então o que podemos fazer?
Bem, acontece que há um
algoritmo clássico bem conhecido que pode nos ajudar, chamado o
algoritmo de frações contínuas.
E o que esse algoritmo pode fazer é tomar nossa aproximação
Y sobre dois elevado a M e nos dizer qual fração U sobre V,
escrita nos mínimos termos, e onde U e V são ambos
inteiros menores que N está mais próxima da nossa aproximação.
É um algoritmo verdadeiramente fascinante, e se você estiver interessado nele, definitivamente vale a pena conferir.
Ele está muito estreitamente relacionado ao algoritmo de Euclides para
calcular MDCs de fato.
Mas não vou dizer nada
mais sobre ele neste vídeo.
O ponto é que se temos uma boa
aproximação para alguma fração para a qual o numerador e
o denominador não são muito grandes,
o algoritmo pode recuperar a fração, e é isso que estamos fazendo aqui.
E agora ficamos exatamente com
a mesma pergunta de antes, que é quanta precisão precisamos?
E acontece que
exatamente o mesmo limite que tínhamos antes funciona nesse caso.
E então escolher M exatamente
da mesma forma que antes também funciona aqui.
Agora isso não vai necessariamente
nos dizer R.
O que vamos aprender se usarmos
precisão suficiente, é J sobre R, mas isso será uma
fração nos mínimos termos.
Então poderíamos ter azar no sentido de que essa escolha aleatória de J poderia ter fatores comuns com R,
e eles estarão ocultos para nós. No pior caso por exemplo, poderíamos obter J igual a zero e não aprenderemos absolutamente nada.
Mas esse é literalmente o único
caso em que não aprendemos nada.
Em geral, vamos pelo menos
obter um fator não trivial de R, e se formos capazes de sortear amostras aleatórias
e obter psi J para diferentes escolhas de J, podemos de fato recuperar
R com alta probabilidade calculando o mínimo múltiplo comum
de todos os denominadores
que observamos. E isso na verdade não
requer muitas amostras.
A conclusão é que algumas escolhas de J vão ocultar fatores de R, mas escolhas aleatórias de J
não serão capazes de ocultar os
fatores de R por muito tempo.
Então essa é a ideia. Resta considerar a implementação e em particular descobrir
o quanto ela custa.
A essência da ideia, para calcular a ordem de um
dado elemento A em ZN estrela é aplicar o procedimento de estimação de fase
à operação MA.
Vamos descobrir qual é
o custo de fazer isso como função do comprimento de N maiúsculo, que vou denotar por n minúsculo.
Aqui está um circuit para a estimação de fase. Vamos precisar de n minúsculo qubits na parte inferior do circuit
para codificar elementos de ZN em binário. Então temos N qubits de controle no topo e n minúsculo qubits na parte inferior,
o que é legal porque corresponde com os nomes que
usamos anteriormente na aula.
Para contar o
número de gates de que precisamos para o circuit completo, vamos focar primeiro no custo das operações unitárias controladas.
Se usarmos as técnicas
da aula anterior, a aula seis, podemos implementar MA usando O grande de n minúsculo ao quadrado gates
usando algoritmos clássicos eficientes para aritmética módulo N.
Vou pular os detalhes neste vídeo, mas como várias outras
coisas que mencionei, você pode ler mais sobre isso no material escrito para a aula.
Não é suficiente no entanto
implementar apenas MA.
Também precisamos implementar MA ao quadrado, MA elevado à quarta potência, à
oitava potência, e assim por diante
até MA elevado a uma potência que é exponencial em M.
E sabemos que vamos precisar que M seja linear em n minúsculo
para obter precisão suficiente.
Essa é uma grande preocupação,
e levantei isso anteriormente.
Se fôssemos implementar potências
de MA simplesmente iterando MA, estaríamos em apuros porque todas essas iterações de MA
incorreriam em custo exponencial.
Felizmente, podemos usar um truque para evitar esse crescimento no custo.
O que podemos fazer é o seguinte, para cada potência K que precisamos.
Primeiro, calculamos A elevado à
potência K, módulo N.
Esse é o problema de exponenciação modular que mencionei na aula seis.
E pode ser resolvido eficientemente. E isso é algo que podemos fazer com um computador clássico.
Esse cálculo não
precisa ser realizado por um quantum circuit de forma alguma.
Então vamos deixar B ser o resultado.
Então B é um elemento de ZN estrela.
E segundo, no lugar de MA elevado à potência K, simplesmente usamos um circuit para MB.
E é isso. B é apenas algum elemento de ZN estrela, então o custo para implementar MB
é O grande de n minúsculo ao quadrado.
Em resumo, o que estamos fazendo é exponenciar em ZN em vez de exponenciar
um quantum circuit.
Mas a operação que realmente obtemos
é a mesma de qualquer jeito. É apenas multiplicação por A, K vezes.
Isso é um tipo de milagre de fato. E não seríamos capazes de
resolver o problema de encontrar a ordem ou fatorar inteiros eficientemente
com um computador quântico
se não fosse por isso.
E agora que sabemos que cada uma das
operações unitárias controladas, incluindo as potências, pode ser implementada
a custo O grande de n ao quadrado, podemos contar o número total
de gates de que precisamos.
Temos N Hadamard gates, e como M é igual
a O grande de n minúsculo, o custo é O grande de n minúsculo.
Temos M operações unitárias controladas que cada uma tem custo O grande de N ao quadrado.
Então o custo total aqui
é O grande de N ao cubo.
E finalmente, a quantum Fourier transform tem custo O grande de n ao quadrado.
Então o custo total é O grande de N ao cubo.
Em particular, vemos que mesmo com nosso
truque de exponenciação modular, o custo das operações unitárias controladas domina.
Mas ainda assim, o custo
é polinomial em n minúsculo.
Também há alguns
cálculos clássicos necessários, como calcular as exponenciações modulares e executar o algoritmo de frações contínuas,
mas esses cálculos
também têm custo polinomial. E de fato, podem ser feitos em O grande de N ao cubo operações também.
Resta apenas um problema, e é que precisamos ter um desses autovetores.
Como podemos fazer isso?
A solução é na verdade muito simples. Não executamos o circuit
em um autovetor.
Simplesmente executamos ele no estado um, ou seja, a codificação
binária do número um, que estamos pensando
como um elemento de ZN.
Então vamos fazer essa
substituição no diagrama.
A razão pela qual isso funciona é por causa dessa equação aqui.
O estado cat um é de fato
uma superposição uniforme dos R autovetores dos quais
temos falado.
E isso não é imediatamente óbvio, mas se você calcular a
soma, deve obter cat um.
E se executarmos o circuit nesse estado, a saída que obteremos
será exatamente a mesma do que se tivéssemos escolhido J aleatoriamente
e executado o procedimento no
autovetor psi J.
Novamente, isso não é óbvio, mas uma análise revela que é verdade.
E finalmente, é isso. Temos um algoritmo quântico eficiente
para encontrar a ordem.
Há uma parte muito curta
da aula restante e diz respeito à relação entre a fatoração de inteiros
e o encontro de ordem.
Mencionei que se pudermos resolver o problema de encontrar a ordem eficientemente, então também podemos fatorar
inteiros eficientemente.
E quero dar muito brevemente a ideia principal de como isso funciona.
É completamente clássico. Essa parte na verdade não tem nada
a ver com computação quântica.
Aqui está um método para encontrar
um fator não trivial de um dado inteiro positivo N.
E a propósito, esse método só funciona quando N é um número ímpar, e não é um número primo
elevado a uma potência.
Esses dois casos quando N
é par ou uma potência de primo podem ser tratados separadamente.
Há métodos clássicos eficientes tanto para detectar quanto para
tratar esses dois casos.
Esse método é probabilístico. Ele pode falhar, mas a
probabilidade de falha será no máximo um meio,
e podemos simplesmente executá-lo
várias vezes independentemente para reduzir a probabilidade
de erro exponencialmente rápido.
Primeiro, escolhemos A entre
dois e N menos um aleatoriamente, de forma uniforme.
Então calculamos o MDC de A e N.
E se o MDC acontecer
de ser maior que um, então tivemos uma sorte incrível.
O MDC será um fator de N e podemos simplesmente produzi-lo como saída e parar.
Caso contrário, o algoritmo continua e agora sabemos que A está em ZN estrela.
E agora calculamos a ordem de A, que é onde precisamos de um computador quântico.
Ou talvez tenhamos uma forma diferente
de calcular a ordem. O algoritmo realmente não
se importa de onde vem, mas a única forma que sabemos
como fazer isso eficientemente
é com um computador quântico.
Se a ordem de R for par, então calculamos o MDC de
A elevado à potência R sobre dois menos um com N.
E se esse MDC for maior que um, então novamente temos um fator de N, então o produzimos como saída e paramos.
Caso contrário o algoritmo falhou. E nesse caso podemos
voltar ao início e escolher um A diferente
e esperar por um resultado melhor
da próxima vez.
E é isso. E a propósito, assim que
encontrarmos um fator de N, podemos recursar sobre esse fator
e dividir por esse fator até termos uma fatoração prima de N.
Então por que isso deve funcionar?
Bem, há dois pontos principais. O primeiro é que como A elevado à potência R é congruente a um módulo N,
temos que N divide A
elevado à potência R menos um.
Essas duas afirmações
são na verdade equivalentes. Essa é a definição de mod N que você vai encontrar nos livros de teoria dos números.
Segundo, se R for par, então essa equação que
temos aqui é verdadeira.
Essa é a fórmula bem conhecida
para a diferença de quadrados.
Na verdade, a equação é verdadeira para todo R, mas precisamos que R sobre dois seja
um inteiro no passo quatro.
E então se juntarmos os dois fatos, vemos que todo fator primo de N deve dividir uma das duas
expressões entre parênteses,
porque essa é a única forma
de N poder dividir o produto.
Agora, poderia ser que todo
único fator primo de N divide a primeira
expressão entre parênteses e não a segunda, mas para nosso A aleatório,
isso não é muito provável. E então quando calculamos
o MDC no passo quatro, é provável que obtenhamos o produto
de alguns dos fatores primos
de N, mas não todos.
Para analisar isso cuidadosamente
requer alguma teoria dos números, mas é teoria dos números bastante básica.
Então se você achar a teoria dos números
interessante e quiser aprender mais sobre ela, tente trabalhar nessa análise.
Trabalhar em coisas assim é uma excelente forma de aprender mais, mas vou deixar isso para você.
E esse é o fim da aula. Nesta aula, cobrimos
o problema de estimação de fase, como podemos resolvê-lo eficientemente
em um computador quântico,
e como podemos aplicar a solução para obter um algoritmo quântico de custo polinomial para a fatoração de inteiros.
Espero que você participe comigo na próxima aula, que é sobre o algoritmo de busca quântica de Grover.
Até a próxima.